Speaker 1: I have never seen
anything like this. Maybe ever.
A soaking wet. Donald Trump. Why can't they turn
up the AC? It's his own house after all. A soaking
wet Donald Trump, who has barely left his home
in the months since he declared he was running
for president. Why isn't he leaving his house? We
don't know. Was interviewed by his own lawyer as
if she's a news anchor journalist on Oann. And
it still was a disastrous interview. Christina
Bobb is an anchor on Oann One America News, and
she is one of Donald Trump's lawyers who tried to
run interference during the entire FBI Mar a Lago
search warrant. She interviewed Trump as if it's
just a journalist. And it was still so humiliating
for Donald Trump. Why is he always soaking wet? We
don't know. Is it hyperhidrosis? Is it flop sweat?
We just don't know. Listen to this first segment.
Speaker 2: Select committee they'll look
at and everything other than two things
they don't want to know about. Nancy
Pelosi turning down 10,000 soldiers.
Speaker 1: Because she didn't. Nancy Pelosi did
not turn down 10,000 soldiers. Trump insists he
asked for 10,000 soldiers. There is
not a shred of evidence that Donald
Trump made that request for January 6th.
Speaker 2: She didn't look like the look.
Have you had 10,000 soldiers for, you
know, hundreds of people? They wouldn't
have gotten anywhere near the place.
Speaker 1: It would now consider how
funny it is that when it comes to the
turnout in general. On January 6th,
Trump says there might have been a million people
at his speech at which he encouraged them to go to
the Capitol. But now he says, Well, there were
only a few hundred people at the Capitol. Now,
of course, both are lies. There were not a million
people at his speech, and there were way more than
a few hundred people. There are 700 defendants who
allegedly committed crimes at the Capitol. There
were, of course, thousands, tens of thousands of
people. But every number Trump gives is a lie.
Speaker 2: There would have been no no January
6th. There wouldn't have been a January six.
Speaker 4: So maybe the problem.
Speaker 2: Oh, no. Well, there are a lot
of people that think they wanted it, but.
Speaker 1: She's trying to help him.
But he won't take the life preserver.
Speaker 2: But if you had soldiers historically,
and I recommended it strongly.
Speaker 1: That's a lie.
Speaker 2: But it's her decision. She's
the one that has to make the decision.
Speaker 1: That's also a lie.
Speaker 2: And nobody likes talking
about that. But we recommended because I knew
that a lot of people were coming down. They
were coming down because they thought the
election was rigged. We know. And they were
right. They were. That's why they were coming down
and that's why they don't want to talk about that.
And they don't want to talk about the rigged
election. They all they want to talk about is
the people and those people are being.
Speaker 1: We just keep focusing on all
of the people that Trump motivated to
commit acts of violence and criminality,
but not the fact that the election was
rigged because the election wasn't rigged.
Speaker 2: Beat it. Many of them are being
treated unbelievably unfairly. Compare that to
what happened in the riots where Black Lives
Matter and Antifa killed people. They kill people.
Speaker 1: I have found no evidence that Black
Lives Matter and Antifa killed people. There
is an article that's a couple years old from
The Guardian which says anti-Fascists linked
to zero murders in the US in 25 years that
data has changed. There is now one homicide
in the US that has been tentatively linked
to a self-described anti-fascist. I don't
think it's convenient to Trump to compare
the numbers to right wing violence in the United
States. Let's go to a little bit more of this
interview. And it is really wacky.
Speaker 4: I think Biden would
look as obviously bad.
Speaker 1: As this is, by the way,
a compilation from our friend Erin Roper.
Speaker 4: Does. If it hadn't been so starkly
contrasted with yours, huge success of an.
Speaker 2: Administration right there.
Speaker 1: That's a beautiful journalistic
question, huh? Your administration was so
good. Is that part of why Biden looks terrible?
Speaker 2: The Keystone Pipeline, Keystone XL.
Yeah, it was all done. There were starting.
And, you know, the sad part is that's a union
job. And the union head endorsed Biden. Right.
And like immediately after. Yes. Into office,
he terminated the Keystone pipeline. Right.
And that union should get rid of that guy.
And a guarantee of the union workers voted
for me. I bet you most of them voted for me.
Speaker 1: But I bet you they didn't.
Speaker 2: The head of the union endorsed
Biden and then Biden terminated it immediately.
He didn't say what he's going to said he was
going to look it over. Right. But he didn't.
Mary is another lie. See, that's the big lie,
not us. They're the big lie.
Speaker 1: Just it's just free
word association. And Christina Bobb is
desperate to help. But she just can't.
Speaker 2: And the big lie on the election
to not us. It's the exact opposite. Right.
And then you have the UN Select Committee they
look at and everything other than two things.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So then that's the
segment we already saw. Let's skip
forward a little bit to just a little more.
Speaker 2: Minneapolis, they burned down. Look
at what happened in Seattle, where they took
over a big part of the city. And Portland,
just like people put up wooden storefronts because
they get knocked down as fast as they put them
up and people are getting killed and nothing
happens to those people. And yet with the other,
it's it's like incredible. Not only
nothing happens. You have people, Democrats
trying to get bail money to get them out when
most of them are in jail anyway. So it doesn't
matter. But compare that treatment with the
treatment that these people are getting.
And it's just a very, very unfair situation.
Speaker 1: It's it's just all over the
place. Trump now cares about pretrial
detention when it comes to the people
that committed acts of violence defending him.
Speaker 4: Right. So and I know we're almost out
of time, but I wanted to ask you one more.
Speaker 1: As riveting as this is, sir,
we are almost out of time. Trump's
like, I'll say, 4 hours. I'm not
doing anything. I don't leave my house.
Speaker 4: This is just one of the many
great pictures that you pull for your book about
the rallies. But what do you think about the
rallies? I know you have one coming up in North.
Speaker 2: Carolina, South Carolina. We have
another one coming up in Georgia very soon.
No, the rallies are incredible. The rallies,
honestly, and you know it because you go
to some of them, they're bigger now than
they were before the election.
Speaker 1: That's, of course,
untrue. And Donald Trump does appear
to be getting back into the rallies.
What the point of the rallies will be,
we don't know. But at least in theory,
he's a presidential candidate. I guess he'll talk
about the fact that he's running wacky stuff as
delusional as ever. Let's talk about one bit of
not so good news for the failed former president.